hey guys Ryan right here I'm gonna be
watching the trailer for gone girl it
stars Bennifer Affleck and it's directed
by David little Fincher it's supposed to
be you know David Fincher's next big
masterpiece I like the first trailer I
saw four gone girl it was a good tease
I'm very interested in watching this I
really liked David Fincher movies a lot
and he's good at like these crime
thrillers were plots Escalade and build
and then like the mysteries all closing
in you know I I like a good film like
that you know like seven zodiac all good
[ __ ] Girl with the Dragon Tattoo and he
always gets like the most beautiful
cinematography in his films too so yeah
I'm really looking forward to seeing
this I hope Ben Affleck does a good job
because um you know he's the next Batman
every performance he's doing that's
being released before Batman vs Superman
people are really keeping an eye on him
to make sure he's doing a good job so
don't [ __ ] this one up and have like
girls we know it's a lot of faith in men
versus Superman cuz people were already
not excited about you being bad Nick Don
you're probably the most hated man in
America right now did you kill your wife
Nick what you of the porcelains as ever
and told us marriage is hard work not
for me and Nick
as you all know my wife Amy Elliott
Dunne disappeared three days ago I had
nothing to do with the disappearance of
my life I have nothing to haunt
Sammy got friends we can talk to no not
really you don't know if she has friends
you don't know what she does all day and
you don't know your wife's blood type
she's being a good guy so everybody
could see it all you really don't like
India I'm trying to do is being nice to
the people who are volunteering to help
find Amy I will practice believing my
husband loves me but I could be wrong
you see that guy in the glasses before
Amy is the kind of girl who attracts
admirers whoever took her is bound to
bring her back no watch'n never kiss me
I saw Amy's treasure huh seen this girl
around here yeah I remember I know you I
saw you with the volunteer side I wanted
out what's your war she wanted a gun we
are all scared but we are all here now I
feel like something to be jettisoned if
necessary I feel like I could disappear
the hallmark of a sociopath is a lack of
entropy and you lost a lot of blood in
there then somebody mopped it up why
they mop up the blood if they're trying
to stage a crime scene whatever they
found I think it's safe to assume that
it's very bad I find media
I would join you is if you're doing a
deposition what to say what not to say
trained monkey trained monkey who
doesn't get lethal injection she's you
alive
you assaulted her it's not good for you
a hitter it's not even close absolutely
not I never touched her me now they've
nick is involved in the disappearance of
our daughter without a body without a
murder weapon their only hope is a
confession I know anything you need to
tell me how was your marriage Nick
asking me if I killed my wife man of my
dreams this man of mine think what about
my son Newark this man may kill me in
her own words this man
kill me you ever hear the expression the
simplest answers often the correct one
actually I've never found that to be
true them who's gonna give me a lot of
anxiety I feel it like anything with
mystery solving and closing in on the
case and all that I get really anxious
in the theaters for some reason but I
like it it's a good you know escapism
right I really like Ben Affleck actually
you know a lot of people have been
bagging on them but I think is a great
[ __ ] actor I mean he used to suck but
now he's good
granny is just the trailer i I don't
believe Ben Affleck is the killer but to
you know to see someone in that position
of being accused of murder who likes it
I don't know why I'm laughing it's just
such a horrible situation to be in if
you did not do it like oh my god
remember the fugitive like damn for you
really fell for Harrison Ford in that
one yeah that's just how I feel right
now for Ben Affleck like I hope you
didn't kill your wife or else these
feelings are unjust anyway guys um thank
you for letting me know that trailer was
out if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe subscribe subscribe subscribe
subscribe subscribe subscribe
alright well um I'm gonna do some shout
outs brand new thing I'm doing reviewers
183 he wanted a shout out well reviewers
183 I think you have your own review
channel if you do go check out his
channel BAM marketing networking look at
us go youtubers collaborating but then
again I have no idea if you actually
have your own channel so if you don't
then don't waste your time going to this
guy's page Layton's apprentice to shut
up for me even if I haven't requested
one until now that would be awesome it
is awesome that you asked for a shout
out you know there was a time where
shout outs were decided upon
you know deserved now people just ask
and I'm actually okay with that Layton's
apprentice to I don't know what a Leyden
is I don't know what your apprentice to
but why aren't you apprentice one hmm
let whose apprentice one
why are you number two if there's one
thing my idol Ricky Bobby taught me
is that if you're not first you're last
so get on the Layton's you mother-effer
be man four six six seven can you say
shout out to Tim and just stare into the
camera for five seconds would make my
life complete Tim